signs and get ready to cheers to
Oktoberfest The Hofbrau house is the
place to be and here is the place to be
today because look at the setup that
they brought we're talking all things
celebrity cake toppings giant pretzels
loud music here to tell us all about it
we have Jessica and Kevin thank you both
so much for being here thanks for having
us so this looks amazing and it just
shows the food the drink everything you
guys offer at Hofbrauhaus let's get
right to the food tell us some of the
stuff you guys offer over there oh yeah
I would like to start on uh on the right
side there we have our appetizer Tower
with radish on top our assorted cold
cuts and assorted of Bavarian cheese
then we go over two different Masters
what we are offering we imported them
from Germany we have our obatsa that's
our famous starter in Germany that one
is made out of butter cream cheese and
our imported Bavarian cream cheese um
Bavarian cheese it's delicious I've had
before I love it awesome yeah then I got
some sausages with me and also the pork
knuckle which is served with a potato
dumpling with a bread dumpling and also
some red cabbage and now the famous oven
roasted pork roast you got all the good
stuff and even even the big pretzels I
know that those are intended to share
but when I go I order one just for
myself and I don't let anyone share with
me because they're that good and
also makes Hofbrauhaus so much fun are
the cake toppings and everyone is up
dancing cheerzing standing on tables
it's allowed to stand on the furniture
There tell us a little bit about those
cake toppings and seriously it's so much
fun so every Friday and Saturday night
we kick off the evening by tapping a
cake and the celebrity is going to do
that every Friday and Saturday tonight
we will have the cast of wow and
tomorrow we have Sarah Hester Ross
tapping the cake next week we also have
Ricardo Laguna the Fantasy Girls Frankie
Moreno is coming up at the end of the
month thank you and you know they tip a
keg of Oktoberfest beer and then we
serve it to all the guests at the
restaurant and it's the same beer that
millions of people enjoyed at the
Oktoberfest in Munich Germany yeah so
you guys really bring the authentic
celebrations here to Las Vegas and I
don't know how you don't run out of beer
because everyone in there is drinking
those big signs all the time but it's so
much fun we're excited for the cake
toppings hofbra house is great year
round but especially for Oktoberfest
thank you both for being here so much
fun I'm stealing that pretzel don't tell
anyone don't miss the celebrity toppings
with the cast of WoW tonight and singer
Sarah Hester Ross tomorrow at night a
lot of exciting stuff